Tatyana Ali steps out for her first
appearance since announcing she's
expecting you've got incredible
pregnancy glow and you're looking
gorgeous about the bronzer okay Tatyana
showed off her growing belly in a blue
Zac Posen gown at the black girls rock
event in New Jersey and The Fresh Prince
Alam tells ET exclusively how she's
feeling after her big reveal I'm
actually a little bit overwhelmed we you
know made that announcement but I wasn't
expecting all of the love that we've
received and all of the congratulations
it's been so beautiful it's made the
blessing even if it could be you know
even more extravagant and more brilliant
the actress says she wants to keep her
due date and the baby's gender a secret
but rush is about what the couple wants
for their first child healthy healthy
and happy the mom-to-be
is also preparing to say I do to her
fiance dr. Vaughn raspberry do you think
it's gonna be a big blowout wedding
star-studded or are you looking for
something a little more intimate I think
we want intimacy we want to celebrate
it's about love and our family and our
very close friends might we see any of
your coma co-stars from Fresh Prince at
the wedding well I haven't sent out the
invitation so I haven't gotten my RSVPs
yeah we'll see you said yeah